hey everyone this is Kevin from the
chesswebsite.com and today we're going
to be going over the matsukovic Gambit
which drives from the alakine defense
which starts out with E4 and then Knight
F6 upon typically just pushes forward
with E5 attacking the Knight Knight to
D5 and then just continuing to put
pressure on that Knight with C4
Knight to B6 the most common move and
now y has a few options one of the most
common ones is D4 but right behind that
you could just play C5 attacking the
knife Knight's usually just going to
come back to D5 in the center of the
board white can no longer attack it with
the pawns so Knight to C3
it's pretty standard here after black
exchange and white takes on C3 now the
main line for black is to play D6
white is now going to play the move
Bishop to G5 and this is the matsukovic
Gambit that we're going to be going over
today it has an extremely high win rate
and you'll start to see how difficult it
is for Black to play
that's running through databases to see
how often this position arises and the
most common response from black even if
you put it through the engine is to play
Pawn takes on E5 and this is really
where the fun starts
for white because if you look at and say
well I don't really see how White's
going to get a huge Advantage here the
Queens exchange off the board uh yeah
black can't Castle anymore after the the
king takes here but once the Queens can
adopt the board doesn't really matter if
you can Castle or not but White's not
looking to Castle instead they're gonna
play the move Queen B3 now this bishop
on G5 it looks somewhat out of place
it's not really attacking the weak
Square on F7 which is typically the
square you want to attack for white
early in the game The Queen Is on B3 for
sure but the bishop is not so what is
the bishop doing and what are the
threats that white actually has that's
what we're going to be going over today
what I like about this Gambit is it's
one of those that if you can play it
against your opponent which if you play
against the elephant alicon defense you
will have a lot of opportunities because
none of the lines that we looked at uh
were really that crazy it really just
comes down to if you want to continue to
chase that Knight away instead of
playing D4 early on you'll get a chance
to play this but you'll really see that
black has a difficult time dealing with
let's look at some of the threats you
can see immediately we're pinning down
this Pawn on E7 to the queen so they
can't just play you know E6 we would
take their queen that would be a
disastrous move
let's kind of go through some of the
other terrible moves they could have and
then we'll look at the best move for
black which I think is difficult to find
so one option they have is Knight C6
this is probably their their worst
option but it'll start to give you an
idea of the threats that white has white
Canal play the move Rook 2 D1 this is
attacking the queen you can start to see
the queen doesn't have a lot of good
options as far as where it is going to
go so let's look at a few of them one is
Bishop to E6 is okay if you're gonna
take my queen I'm gonna take your queen
as well but unfortunately this exchange
is not going to work out we can play
Queen takes on B7 we're still attacking
their Queen okay so how do they stop
this if they just bring their Bishop
back D7 well the exchange is not going
to work we take their Bishop they take
our Rook we take their Rook on A8 check
and then they definitely don't want to
exchange Queens because we're up in
material and we want to exchange down
they don't want to so maybe Knight d8
this Knight's awkwardly place that's not
going to be good and then we played
Knight F3 we're up in material and we
should have a very easy in-game from
here if we come back if they decide okay
I want to play Bishop E6 that's not
going to be a good trade for us what if
they just play Bishop D7
anytime they move that Bishop off of
this C8 Square they're just setting
themselves up for so much pain if they
come to E6 we took on B7 but here what
they've also neglected is the F7 Square
so now we can play Bishop to C4 and now
we're eyeing down both our Queen and our
Bishop on the F7 Square we already
talked about they cannot play E6 which
is what they want to play because that
leaves their Queen hanging on d8 so we
have this threat here in the center of
the board neither of their pawns on D or
the E file can stop this they don't have
their Knight that started on G8 to stop
this threat so how do they really do
anything the knights on C6 can't stop it
they don't have a lot of good options
from here
maybe they play Queen C8 just trying to
give their King some Square to go to
okay well now we can just take with our
Bishop on F7 now their King can't Castle
we still have our Queen so it's not
going to be good for black you can see
the king is now on an open file with our
Rook on D1 this is not gonna be good we
can get more material involved into the
game and there's no safe squares now for
black to continue they can't get their
Pawn out to E6 to get their dark Square
Bishop involved it's being pinned down
by the bishop here we can get our Knight
involved here you can see we're adding a
lot of pressure this bishop on D7 is
pinned down the Queen's not going
anywhere neither of the Rooks are going
anywhere as well so that's what happens
if early on they play that Knight to C6
not going to be a good option the next
option that you could see is just the
move F6 attacking the bishop here on G5
now it's nice is for white we can pretty
much disregard this bishop because we
have a stronger attack and that is
bringing the Rook over here to D1 that's
why it's so important you bring your
queen to B3 attacking the weak Square on
F7 and then that opens up you can get
your Rook over to D1 and this D file is
completely open okay so how do they stop
this well now they because they're
Knights not on C6 it does have the
option they can either defend the square
on D7 with their bishop or their Knight
so let's look at both them first we'll
look at uh Bishop 2d7 I like to think of
this as black loses quickly where Knight
to D7 black loses slowly but we'll look
at both options you can really see uh
how bad this gets for black here Bishop
D7 blocking this
but now as soon as they play their
Bishop you've probably seen this before
we take on B7 now they could take our
Bishop yes but now we can take their
Rook that's definitely going to be a
better exchange for us and now they've
opened up their King side of the board
this f file is no longer secure for them
and they're kings in the center of the
board with their dark Square Bishop
still in a tough spot maybe now they
play E6 to open up for their dark Square
Bishop we can play B4 that solidifies
this Pawn structure so this bishop can't
really go anywhere yeah I could come to
E7 potentially but now we just play F3
we're attacking the pawn on E5 uh we can
gobble up material here on E7 if we want
to we can centralize our Queen we're
still pinning down this bishop on D7 uh
from our Rook to the queen so they just
have a tough tough spot here and yes
they can Castle on the king side but
they don't really have a good solid
structure and since we are up in
material since we took the Rook we
should have an easy in-game from here
now if we come back instead of Bishop D7
what if they play Knight to D7 this is
what I like to think of is if black
wants to lose a long game or Bishop to
D7 I think it's more of a quicker loss
because now white has a really fun move
and that is Queen E6 and it gets pretty
tricky for black before we had Queen on
B3 and we're looking to bring our Bishop
to C4 where now we can reverse it
anytime your Bishop is supporting your
queen
the threat gets even crazier for black
to deal with because once we get our
Bishop to C4
it's pretty much game over unless there
is a way for this King to move they
almost have to play C6 because without
that how are they really going to
continue remember if they look at it and
say well I'll just go ahead and attack
this queen I'll just take this Knight or
this Pawn on C5 with my knight remember
that Knight is pinned down by our Rook
here so yes we can take their Queen they
can't just take our Queen back this is
check so this is a really really tough
predicament that we are putting them in
they really need to be playing C6 in
this spot from here we're going to
continue Bishop C4 threatening mates on
F7 they kind of need to play their Queen
out to A5 just so their King can come to
this d8 Square we can play Bishop to E3
defending the square on uh C5 now their
Bishop here on f8 is kind of blocked off
it's not a great square and so you can
see their King is going to be stuck in
the center of the board here and we're
attacking this area of the board our
Bishop and queen are eyeing down this F7
Square they're probably going to play
King to d8 we could play Knight to E2
start to rearrange where our Knights
going it can come to uh G3 then E4 and
then really start to put a lot of
pressure on our opponents can even come
up here to F5 and start to attack some
of these critical squares on E7 and a G7
so we have a ton of options of how we
are going to continue in this spot this
all comes back to if they decide early
on
he would play Queen to B3 and they say
hey let's go ahead and attack that
Bishop on uh G5 it's just not gonna work
out great form
next option we're going to look at is
instead of Knight to C6 and pawn F6 what
if they play their Bishop now if they
play Bishop two E6 you've probably seen
this story before they attack Our Queen
we just come up and take on B7 as soon
as they play their queen or their excuse
me their bishop and they're not
defending the pawn on F7 we can just
come up here take this Pawn on B7 and we
are in a good spot now since we're
attacking The Rook they're probably
going to play Knight to D7 but then we
can Castle on the queen side
gives us uh you know it's kind of the
same thing as far as getting the Rook to
D1 but hey it also gives us a little
safer path for our King also allows us
to really throw everything if we want to
on the king side of the board and not
have to worry about a late game uh
saving from our King from just a
structure standpoint they could play
Rook B8 attacking Our Queen uh that's
fine we can just play Queen C6 now we're
putting the queen and the Rook uh both
on this D7 Square the Knight can no
longer move it's not just pinned down
from The Rook to the queen but now it's
pinned down to the the king and so it
definitely can't move this bishop it's
really in a tough spot it was attacking
Our Queen but now it's in no man's land
so that can't go anywhere maybe they now
decide okay I need to get my Bishop here
to G7 Castle on the king side
but while they're trying to just save
playing defense we can just develop our
pieces Knight to F3 here uh Bishop G7 we
could play Bishop comes back to E3
they could cast on the king side uh but
as soon as our Bishop comes back this
also opens up for a knight to come to uh
G5 they could play Bishop F5 we could
play H3 and then they have a couple
options here uh one is if they play E4
you may say well why do they play E4 the
whole reason is once we come up to G4
now this Knight can come to E5 before
when the pawn was on E5 it could not and
so this now gives us the option once
they've Castle on the king side they
don't have to worry too much about us
taking their Queen with check they've
castled that's no longer a threat we've
kind of looked at that one so Pawnee for
we're gonna come up here to G4
then they played Knight E5
but then we take their Queen they take
our Queen but then we take on f8 they
take on f8s and then we take the
material on F5 this exchange does not
work out for them at all Rook to G1 now
it's on this open file this is going to
be extremely bad for black now if we
come back if we play H3 maybe they
decide to play H5 instead okay great we
can still just push up with uh G4
yes we could see an exchange uh right
here but after they take we have a lot
of threats here as well we could even
just play Bishop two uh H3 here if we
want to because now we have our Knights
on a G5 we've opened up the H file we
can get both of our Rooks on the H file
we just have a ton of threats that they
are going to have to deal with going to
be very very difficult this is why I say
that this is kind of the losing and the
long approach black more than likely is
going to lose with all the threats that
white has but it does take a little bit
longer for white to actually win this
game
so let's come back to the very beginning
of this after Queen to B3 the best move
for black so that they don't just lose
automatically
is kind of an odd move but it's Queen to
D7 remember the main theme around this
for white is
this bishop on G5 and the Queen on B3
because we can bring our work to D1
really puts their Queen in a tough spot
and because they're queens in a tough
spot they just can't do a ton so getting
their Queen to D7 is the best play
but that's fine we can just play Knight
to uh F3 it's gonna be more of a regular
development from us we're attacking the
pawn on E5 we can get our light Square
Bishop involved into the game similar to
the other variations with C4 we can
Castle on the king side can't Castle
through Jackson I'm not going to be
casting on the queen side but this is
going to be a very solid structure for
white and you can see Black's already
blocking off their light Square Bishop
okay well if they want to play Pawn E6
they have a kind of an awkward structure
with double pawns on the e-file just to
get their dark Square Bishop involved
into the game the castle uh so I think
it's going to be difficult even for
black to continue in this position even
if they know the best move which is
Queen D7 just doesn't feel like it's
that great for black so this is why that
if you get to play this white has such a
high win percentage there's just so many
lines that White's gonna be better off
so really enjoy this variation in
alakine defense so if you go up against
it I definitely recommend trying this
out but thank you guys so much for
watching this video if you wouldn't mind
just leaving a comment in the bottom let
me know if you enjoyed it if there's any
other openings you want me to do a video
on or if there's any other types of
videos please let me know that as well
thank you guys so much for watching I'll
see you in the next video